[Musique]
bienvenue à sans filtre le podcast on
parle de ce qu'on veut que nous inviter
dates ci dessus ph quentin avec moi dôme
plan cette semaine au podcast
on reçoit un nouveau visage dans le
monde du rap québécois qui est là depuis
une couple d'années déjà mais qui ont un
succès fulgurant fu chi
ok ok on est aisé est vraiment belle
rencontre ouvrait l'aiguillé ce patch il
on a parlé de lafarge commençons ce live
tout filmé ses influences comme qui
composent comment qui vous voit la
musique la musique une vibration c'est
quasi
jt petty ont tous les deux des fans de
rap des pop up
si vous aimez le sans-fil podcast on a
notre page pétrone qui est active on
commence à avoir une bonne petite
communauté l'as bopp vous pouvez vous y
joindre en cliquant sur le lien dans la
description la tuyaux du contenu
exclusif ont fait décliner on répond à
vos questions et vous avez même la
possibilité poser des questions aux
invités
dirigez-vous vers ceux ci voulaient nous
encourager
sinon abonnez-vous à la chaîne youtube
pour être à l'affût de tous les nouveaux
podcast qui sortent commenté dans les
commentaires ce que vous pensez de cette
conversation l'a ajouté à la
conversation
nous on lis tous les commentaires puis
on aime sur vous lire on peut pour
répondre à tous mais on aime se dire du
moins donc sinon mon pote pièce est
juste rajouter aussi à l'écouté à
l'écouté la toundra baisse des fous qui
pour voir si vous connaissez pas les
voir ce qui fait qu'il ya un nouvel
album qui sort en mai us y aura des
lancements mais il faut qu'ils restent à
l'affût de ce qui est bon pas de casque
bonne écoute
[Musique]
ces pièces ou qui merci
premièrement dernière extreme d'apple
c'est l'excitation c'est vraiment ça
cache en fait la beauty si on étale en
france comme pour faire des shows départ
on est la chose qui est xavier mme sy
qui filme et qui fait du montage est
venu avec nous pour les chefs de cour
qui était doublement payant dans un
montage et sacoches d'ailleurs pas
grosse job loin ces photos je trouve on
va trouver les bonnes ça paraît qu'il ya
les jeux de l'iphone au travail de ce
pays
et avait vraiment comme une petite gamme
vraiment plus c'est en mode vieux films
pineau bonne came genre fait ses gammes
à manille étaient en état la grenoble
puis lui être poli est en suisse avec
aux biens le chef puis dans le feuillage
utilise la petite gamme
[Musique]
il est coté leur fine ce qui serait
quand même insensé que ses vues comme
étant la baston 2d comme pourquoi pas
justement parce que les prochains
captation fait celle ci fait que c'est
plus simple plus haut a annoncé cool
parce que c'est le seul club à part
semble vraiment parents clip tchéquie
ton clip de playoffs puis quand on
arrive de cuba et l a6 toutes les places
qu'on est à la traîne si j'étais allé à
cuba avait gaza
si c'est nous c'est un voyage encore une
fois c'est un voyage qui comme non
seulement 6 des vacances mais en plus en
profite pour faire une promesse
maintenant je pense tout haut si tu pars
en vacances mais termine ton stock
critiquée à l'étranger
ça fait des ajustements le reconnaissait
qu ball et vinales qui monte je citerai
combats a ajouté de quoi mais c'est ce
genre d'hôtel je pense qu'on a les
traits tracés spots parce que parce que
je voyais ménélas barrière ou est-ce que
où est-ce que tu foutais ben justement
l'hôtel legends un hôtel plus loin juste
le temps de sauter là parce que c'était
la petite ville et des chambres au total
et une journée plus totale
jardin minelle par les secours au tél
[Rires]
ouais pas trop loin de finalistes dans
un autre village qui justement ce qu'il
sait comment je peux rester à vie à
l'est mais si tu veux tu peux aller
passer la journée du crémant à l'hôtel
puis il était comme faire de la messe à
venir à l'aise tout mais c'est ce qu'a
dit que ma vie me laisse mon niveau et
ils vont à une autre plage qui quand
même trois heures de toutes les tribunes
ce qui on s'en va en fait c'est tout est
natif de géra pato est en fait c'est son
thiam qui est qui qui travaillent dans
les mines la bauge en fait osciller
travaille aussi la boue tout fait
non ceci indépendamment de quelle mine
travail qui est avant et en ontario où
avant l'ontario et en espagne c'est très
cool mais je sais danser cool c'est
encore le même pourquoi pas travailler
travailler ailleurs dans le monde je
connais un gosse et italie et travaille
au qatari club depuis qu'est l'homme il
viendra pas ici la vie humaine la baule
se passera sans l'annoncer comme ici
à cuba des fois je me penser comme ses
compagnons une bière sur le sol je ne
pensais quand même les personnages
deviennent diesel dominique lui ça va
déplacer longtemps j'ai écouté sa femme
le je pense à arrêter au moins jusqu'aux
lui faudrait lire écouter tout au
complet qui prend ton char voit la
courbe de légende
je le suivais sur instagram puis les
matins alors lui cela tout le temps
quatre heures et demie pour pro quand sa
journée pour les green deal
puis les matins ils y apprennent et sont
celles prises et je regardais sont
certes story pizza légendaire j'écoutais
hier un podcast de joe rogan avec qui le
marquent le doute de
rogers qui il dit c'est joe hogan
or si mike tyson pis c'est ici pendant
qu'il parle il ya toujours un 10% ton
cerveau qui se dit oh my god ce matin
vers motifs utilisés à elle seule mine
de quoi que à cuba comme ans et demi de
coin ombragé oublier non mais c'est pas
vrai c'est plus des électriques un peu
là pour les genres et les asiatiques
font beaucoup de soucis les gens de
mines je me suis pas dupe lancement du
cuivre
non c'est un an vraiment
[Rires]
c'est bon c'est bon pour le mans qui
connaissent pas que ça faisait jaser
ouais suite
regarde mais quand j'étais plus jeune
j'ai mon pas nous mettre beaucoup de
richard déjà coûté sa gueule et je
trouve notamment comment il dit les
choses comme chaque chaque truc sympa
c'est bon trop trop trop trop ce
martelage des sicav qui ai pas pensé à
écrire sur l'yonne une similitude pis
moi qu'est ce t'en penses une similitude
énorme entre eux
ces compositeurs bain ces écrivains et
le sait pas être avec le rap québécois
c'est fou c'est vraiment cédé flotter si
c'est sûr qu'aujourd'hui
musicalement ça se ressemble plus
vraiment mais c'est sûr que tu sais si
c'est vraiment autre coulera pour moi
c'est ça c'est bernard adamus et les
collègues chercheurs des jardins c'est
raoul duguay
c'est flou que je pourrais utiliser
finalement fait qu'étudier pape ou non
mais sinon le flou c'est en gros la paix
mais ces malades justement ce que tu
disais le kiki a pensé à écrire sur ces
jours ci je me le dit souvent
quand j'écoute du rap des bleus chez qui
a pensé à faire c'est ça me rappelle mon
nom est sur l'album il ya des trucs chez
vous ça sent bien dans les démos sont
pas ça mais en fait ça vite paris parce
que ça va pas longtemps non je dirais
que j'ai dû faire au moins 35 beat it
[Musique]
des fois il ya des chansons que ça
ressemble un peu votre foyer des
chansons qui justement betis a peut-être
pas de rapport avec l'album s'appelle
bon ailleurs dans un autre contexte
à quel point ça c'est moyennement qui
fait toutes les bêtes ou web en fait
c'est vraiment comme quoi demain qui se
dit comme le dernier album on est
enregistré et mixé masters avec un saut
de mousse salle amos
non c'est simple le prochain en fait on
s'est dit ah si je me suis acheté un bon
groupe toofan câble et je doit
enregistrer un peu c'est un peu plus
beau parce qu'ils sont nés des poteaux
du sol je sais qu'à man et de
passionnantes un garde-robe ceci fait ma
chambre j'ai gardé mon père m'a
construit des petits meurent pour toute
la pièce est un petit idiot et du ghetto
ça fait ça fait pas un peu gros studio
dès samedi d'importants puits et donc
c'est ça la magie de l'album était clair
que c'est cool parce que quand je reste
chez nous tout seul je peux partir de
soin d'élire le prince a même décroché
mon chez des gens pensent faire ça
devant d'autres personnes non c'est cool
qui est
l'image avec son entourage ça cloud en
studio le ya douze personnes ça c'est
tout c'est bien ça le fait des fois mais
comme je te montre volée tout les goûts
dans la classe sont venus dans ma câble
c'est trop drôle
chaque animal et manu place et c'est
parfait ça prend trop de place
mais c'est cool ça parce que tout peut
si c'est un seul temps que tu utilises
l'est pour jean rif et puis essayer de
faire des sites faire des nouvelles
affaires qui sortent de l'ordinaire
y a personne qui met de pression de
personne par son hôte a pas un acte du
fait quoi qui de la mort de ces moines
dans ce montant je pense pas que c'est
du temps perdu maintenant c'est même ça
de ne rien parce que c'est quand même
c'est un apprentissage mais justement ça
peut-être rien donné qu'ils baptisent
pourrait pas que je refasse le genre de
truc qui ne veut pas même quand ça froid
c'est quand même un apprentissage mais
je le vois comme ça donc c'est sûr qu'il
ya pas eu aucune autre stress déjà pas
quel studio s'affirme dans deux ans ce
qui développe aussi des réflexes et
justement coriace qu'on leur site tout
est adapté
podcast c'est fou qui mais n'y arrivent
sur le beat pitch your friends
je parle beaucoup mais j'étais un gosse
un beau jeune homme de peu de mots donc
et un refrain jarry soins betis avait
des animateurs ils s'ajustent suffit de
trouver de quoi de karachi le même temps
what may chanson sites mondiaux qu'avant
tout c'est vraiment pire équipe de texte
avec le mot est faible
le mariage peut trouver mais c'est
justement trouvé le truc qui tissent et
c'est de la musique célébration
faussaires c'est ça donne le goût de
bouger faudra éphémère tout était
terminé 6e place
complétez avec même si dit de quoi le
super plate mais sa crosse à va être
aucunement comme ceux de quoi de super
bon mais tellement plate que ça va être
un équilibre entre les deux frères
dubois papa papa pour puissant phase où
le soleil plombe sur une nuit étoilée de
la lune et ses piges en la mettant
coyecques travail bit
tu écoutes chez vous toullec ta femme tu
renvoies ce qui arrive des fois même si
je suis avec michel py si l'on fait
maintenant je sais pas moi ça fait une
semaine on sait peu vieillot j'ai fait
quelques bêtises thème ensemble est
celui le ramène cfoot et puis sinon
aussi quand même un sur l'album deux
chansons coproduit avec moi que que nos
secrets du bit aussi fait deux fois
maintenant je trouve que c'est une
maladie of mages pas nécessairement
production ppi tout mais je trouve un
look que je te mords fox c'est si bon
ceccacci les j'écris là dessus plutôt
corsé le michel il rajoute il rajoute la
sauce réduite parce que parfaite sur
l'album il ya deux trois chansons
coproduite aussi à découvrir sans cool
mais maintenant mais n'ont cessé après
ses trois co produites sur comment ça va
être quand même pas grand chose de ce
que vous avez vraiment à 100 pour cent
pour cent je suis le seul le pied et des
belles surprises dans l'album c'est
comme les clips qui vont sortir c'est
plus un produit c'est plus flou qui est
maintenant l'album il ya des belles
surprises des trucs que j'ai c'est que
des tonnes sur tout mais ton travail tu
nommes gayet ou est-ce que tu la gaieté
faut le présenter sous peu un peu
pompeux reguibi mettons budapest d'un
cartoon qui est ce que c'est vraiment
divers l'intériste stylistique mais tant
musicalement dans ton album cheese cake
ou la ronde fait que j'aime sur les
montagnes russes
c'est vrai j'aime penser comme il ya des
albums qui sont très bons c'est un peu
dommage trouve pas ce qu'il veut
oui c'est bon mais c'est pas parce que
tu as trouvé ta réussite de macaronis
truc à manger aussi l'album c'est qu'en
montagne russe et il ya un truc vraiment
plus contents lorsque ces mots la pète
commenté fixé comme ça fasse un peu
comme si jamais ça donne mais très
courte entend parler de john logan qui a
rencontré mike tyson bon de rencontrer
ses idoles toute la dernière année ça a
été une énorme année pour toi ce que tu
as côtoyé des grands du rap tels que tu
devais écouter la cfu dans grandson
genres et toutes parts les vestiges
content que comme le raï cheba accepte
aussi de ce communiqué incluent les
jeunes j'ai justement eu un article de
patrick groulx qui dit donner la place à
la relève humoristique qui fait de la
musique dans le show de patinage et
rigoureux ouais c'est ça on a fêté en
fait t'es michel commun des preuves au
début puis à la fin c'est encore un but
de michel bien sûr mais avec avec mc
cool c'est des belles collaborations
dont une partie publique de pat groulx
qui comprend pas ce qui lui manque c'est
un regard a dit que les rockets mais
c'est parfait les ihu gens se baladent
mais fait dans à travers tout ccc cola
bleus et vit évidemment ces collabos ces
rencontres le ya évidemment correas
l'invention ac au real 2
espèce de mentor non mais j'ai tellement
côté que riasq projectiles du rap
français germany j comme la claque puis
créances est justement des doutes j'ai
vraiment beaucoup écouté et j'écoutais
thérias alaclair une jam épilogue ce du
lard de la ville du nord
le lobby des lobbies oui mais quand j'ai
découvert la raquette j'ai pris la
claque c'est fake comme aussi mon cousin
quand même tu m'as aidé avec ceux qui
comme qui lui fait il fait plus de l'art
visuel en fait c'est un gars de québec
mieux ben de communes à ma famille
habite à québec puis en fait lui aussi
voulu frapper avant les bras puis
vraiment il faut encore du bit par
exemple mais pis c'est comme un des
premiers jeux de mains qui m'a dit qu'à
sa place d'écrire c'est comme trouve ton
flow avant sur le bingo fidèles comme au
pire ça rime pose pas grave mais si on
ressent ce que tu dis ça veut tout dire
les tabourets marry me remets ça va ça
va être beau à l'oreille mais ça veut
rien dire c'est comme ça un peu niaiseux
tandis que justement comme je disais le
terme enregistre milieu effectif comme
au pire ça rime pas mais ce qui était
dit c'est tellement réel dit que comme
personne peut chercher là dessus c'est
juste suffi clarinette fasse rire n'a
pas besoin de grand chose au final la
musique là c'est que la callas n'a
compté qu'un qui est venu ici il ya dix
coups de fouet être content qu'on
recollera qu'on me vole des appareils
puis c'était doublera trois ans talent
de ses shows pied avec mon bras c'est ça
on est arrivé au cégep du vieux
l'acheter même protégé pendant sept ans
écoute parce que j'ai passé mon salaire
cinq circulent mais j'avais des amis au
cégep le maillot c'est carrière à ce
sujet puisque embauché deux qui j'en
passe et j'en pensais payer mon bâtiment
peut envoyer plein d'une file de
personnes peu de jus ce défi avec les
mois puis greg
non mais si nos têtes semaine en écosse
est trop drôle
sur son fil d'actualité
trois jours à peine 16 ans j'ai certes
il s'appelle cela que la patate dans ce
lac la patate coupe le cornichon va
mettre la table grosses têtes de cochon
sandwich au jambon avec la manette sans
fil dans mon premier bateau l'internet
la première chanson exclusive de fous
qu'ils étaient malades c'est très drôle
en plus grandes et petites voix du land
un album premium c'est drôle j'ai dit à
quoi je pensais que j'avais 7 ans
maintenant ce qu'elle chante fiscale
avec mon mon beau frère qui tout de la
gaieté je me suis pété la pisam à malte
ce genre d affaire j'ai une voix de bill
je me suis dit comme riche encore jeune
un peu mais je me suis dit que j'allais
peut-être oui oui des chansons plus tard
guy temps puis moi qui chante des nièces
alors c'est quelque chose de ces faux
cul par est de penser qu'ils veulent
trois ans personne
savez vous comment il explique c'est une
peine juste pour flo j'étais là dessus
immeuble un ennemi j'écoutais beaucoup
de rap câbles mais je perds aucune des
deux équipes j'écoutais j'écoutais
beaucoup de papier blanc cherche
activement un faux dit aussi qu'elle
voulait quelques années leurs activités
c'était comme plus les aides si gentil
sur le seul cela un pige thomas leleu le
rap
comment dire de la relève ça a commencé
tranquillement team s
les derniers rapports la relève qui est
des lobbies le top 5 est vraiment
vraiment un moment je pense je sais pas
qu'est ce qui se passe il manquait pas
de rappeler ces tests et lima et menotté
vraiment je pense au city le fait que je
suis pas moi ça me hania comme arrêter
draper c'est peut-être arrêter aussi un
peu grâce à laisser de la place à
d'autres
mais moi je pense à fait c'est vraiment
qu'est ce qu'il fait c'est vraiment
qu'il est de plus en plus le rap
québécois
de québec et de montréal aussi
commencent à comprendre ans mixait
hasmik c'est exactement c'est parce
qu'avant tu avais vraiment grave de
québec rap de montréal puis en t2 c'est
la guerre jamais trop vite histoire est
tout le temps un peu quand je commence
comme on deux ans et demi de route on
est à côté le train puis de plus en plus
et comme je t'aime on est en studio et
je tends studio cette semaine c'est fait
c'est parfait mais je trouve le faire
des mélanges comme sa maison puis je
pensais juste un mot ce petit même mais
marc citti tu le vois de plus en plus le
rap aussi en général est de plus en plus
de ces comme la halle à savoir si c'est
la musique populaire
piti mais le rap français c'est
maintenant dit les gros articles de rap
français c'est qu'ils me partage plus
comme on parle de rap français on parle
pas de juste leur abda france on parle
je dérape sur du rap québécois voici
footix exporta abboud a pesté jean nuit
le rap francophone exactement c'est même
si je sais que la moitié comprennent peu
de ce qui est normal et très chaude à la
claire pied en belgique - belgique
ouais parce qu'on l'avait justement dans
la chaussée en belgique au lendemain tu
es là on veut voir les choses avec la
traquer le plan tranquille et je voyais
trois belges sans le veut je comprends
vraiment à ses jeux comme far caillou
juste pour l'aide
juste pour vous et un match québécois
puis des fois je comprends pas tout non
plus hein c'est vrai que c'est normal de
ses dc10 lancer des -21 ans qui ont
quitté l'île et rentre dans la salle
c'est la famille qui a pu thym sel et
leurs familles tout ce qui compte c'est
chaud les belges vraiment beaucoup mais
si on est des bons double montée
le beatmaker drôme et elvis l'école hors
du commun qu'on a vu une équipe deux
fois avec richard jean j'associe qu'on
est une soirée avec m
non ce sera beaucoup beaucoup de
rapports belges eux aussi - fait on une
chance c'est que mon agent et lui aussi
s'est exporté montgueux y est allé fort
et quitte à aller faire un échange
allemagne et en belgique
si le cas devait rencontrer raymond
elvis les gars de loft story tout fait
que ça a fait les contacts jeudi quand
ils viennent au québec compte il avait
que quand ça va en belgique contre elle
a vécu ces faits que dans ses coûts lui
c'est s'amender côtoyer des enfants
d'autres scènes d'une certaine façon
assez j'ai un ami qui compte autant du
ski de fond
c'est fou comment sais tu t'en vas à
l'autre bout du monde pour faire coter
ce post est noir l'autre partie du globe
pour faire affecter la bonne stratégie
avait du monde justement à manier comme
tom vendus dans le clip je te vois
revendre ou même ici ça qui part à pied
mme fox qui se fait à cuba
quelle est sa remplissent pas mal dormir
sur la burqa toile à bout ça c'est sûr
que l'on on défriche comme on le fait
déjà pour remplit des salles de 8000
personnes non sans talent
je suis passé au québec n'ont plus fait
quelque chose ça là bas mais non dd on
est des petites salles comme pas mal
rempli les deux cents 200 personnes
c'est bon mais ma lyon serait je pense à
ces lions le seul show gratuit qu'on a
fait et avait même 400 personnes qui
sautait sur des fautes aussi le seul la
seule place au ski et lange est vraiment
comme
tu prenais des maires à paris où ses
impôts mais vraiment à lyon j'ai pris
comme des photos avec les papas les
autres filles c'est vraiment bon c'est
vraiment drôle magnon il me semble
vraiment bien reçu parce que dans toute
cette cette montée du rapt des bleus il
ya un peu aussi le phénomène loud qui a
tracé sur la toile et des encres et cela
s'entend
je passe à la salle comme ya vu un
article de combines hisser leur aussi
dans le temps que je n'ai pas signé avec
7ème ciel donc c'est le la en fait je
pense que ça a vraiment tout comme la
honda fit 56k qui avait fauché marché en
france puis le combiné est fait un genre
de vidéo comme après le rap belge qui
rappe sus qui s'exporte voici maintenant
le rap québécois
voici les cinq artistes et vous devriez
canadien justement il y avait là des
trias alaclair terrou-bi je pense puis à
la fin
fu chi jeté comme un seul but est comme
moi revoir c'est comme taref prendre
n'importe qui d'autre des prix fous qui
le genre même pas signé je n'ai jusqu'à
y est il y ajoute une autre ip gailly
ont fait un fou qui [ __ ] c'est cool
c'est déjà le monde je passais la
journée après steve et des systèmes ciel
mais criant legault on se rend compte
mais c'est comme des parties de maggaiez
apprécier les guettent les terribles de
vue c'est recevoir ses emails
ça doit changer ça ne se doit chez qui
un peu ton band la baisse de l'école qui
légendaire d'en rafler le métier comme
moi je me suis en plus comme si on est
toujours adoré 7ème ciel toujours été
comme le libor que j'écoutais le plus de
musique de raps tcm ciel je me souviens
que comme dans le temps qu on a sorti
notre premier truc plateau s
je me suis dit michel éthique mère ce
qui conduirait le renvoyer à atr
septième ciel et l'eau - zotti vont
venir nous parler qu'en salle et en même
temps on pousserait c'est ce qui est
arrivé puis next in unum investis soit
tellement message de tapas invite ici
comme ailleurs ils doivent les aubois de
l'aube
mais ces pseudos des le même principe
avec les maisons d'édition mais ce n'est
plus l'élection en écriture le pis si
ton truc qui est bon quelqu'un qui va le
trouver ce qu'il va lire le tipi je
comprends car il faut que tu envoies
décès pourtant vos des manuscrits à les
placer sur un faux-pas faut pas le
laisser dormir moins que cinq ou six
noms exacts exactement qu'il faut que
fabre une coupe de tout le monde attend
l'histoire de ce qui s'est fait là qui
présentait harry potter après maison
d'édition qui a été refusé par la maison
d'édition tout mon travail mon manuscrit
refusé mais c'est comme si tout ce passe
au gras pas nécessairement ceux comme ce
qui à mon sens pas les espèces d'exemple
la chose improbable outils les oules où
on les invente le cas mais l'histoire
avec un style qui était pas en mettre un
chalet de pointe était pas intéressé par
l'école n'est pas proche en maths
toutefois ces maps les français j'étais
juste pressé par l'école elle aime se
crée déjà des rêves américains
ces succès story incroyable un métier
mais en réalité je pensais au départ
comme à l'extrême inverse le premier
vous dégagiez qui était sur un autre
genre de [ __ ] dans le même genre mais
qui
j'avais comme le site ont vu que j'étais
quand même ça marche trop g20 avec ça
après petercam
les mots font réconfort comme le trac
compétences de ces comics et comme on
dit souvent mais dans le prochaine album
aussi un truc comme ça c'est son but
avec vendus au japon par exemple jack
comme cette chanson car elle va sortir
mon niveau j'ai trouvé sa fortune il a
un parce que ses tout débuts comme sur
le titre comment est ce que c'est moi
qui ai transmis outil c'est vraiment
drôle tout progrès coûte à chaque fois
mais non infectés justement à l'équipe
de l'or d'esperanza des français puis
après il chantait la french touch comme
romain qui s'appelle choix ces bombes le
final j'avais dit aux gars y et en plus
c'est tellement différent de tout ceci
c'est quelqu'un arrive le pilote et
comme fou qui
il ya six semaines et à lui le direct
qu'ils sont identité gayet en maintenant
la seule tchèque qui reçoit maggaiez c
-b
espace quotidien on va faire un autre
chacun peut dans sa bible mathy com - p
-michel qu'on est dans le studio on
pense pas faire des trucs comme gaiety
on a fait c'est vraiment comme sur le
côté c'est pas toi la formule c'est de
la bonne musique on aime ça mais c'est
pas le genre de musique qui on aime
faire non plus le plus c'est le fond
d'affaires une fois de temps en temps
mais il n'y a pas déjà de james remplacé
bon métier jeudi rahmani mais c'est pas
tant les gens de musique préféré donc et
on fait pas on fait pas juste de succès
mais c'est drôle que c'est ce qui m'a
amené de spotify comme s'égaillent
épuisé mais les deux plus écouté puis
carmen qui c'est drôle parce que ça
c'est pas le genre de beats que j'aime
le plus c'est bête après celle qui au
delà au delà du lac tourner comme tel ce
qu'ils cachent dans ces cas là c'est toi
si tu sais quelque chose là dedans qui
au delà du bate au delà de la mécanique
mais blackos c'est vraiment ton ta
signature qu'il a claqué sa meute ont
justement c'est mon beau père se soit
pas donné mais c'est sûr c'est sur ces
mots mais non c'est en fait c gepa même
la guitare mais night empilait les trois
pôles sachs et depuis c'est comme un
match qui est un genre d'ultra peter sur
l'album mais ne s'est pas déplacé plus
mais
en fait tu pas ma mère il ya pas
vraiment de formule en fait je pourrais
dire le cej
je pense que petit but avec ce qui se
fait appeler c'est même le monde qu'ils
aiment qu'ils imposent toi tu l'aimés ou
tu es fier de ce qui était fait
formule parce que kaka nous y sommes
c'est lui qui a annoncé ça y est
maintenant je pensais vraiment laid le
caecum pop pas dire à gagner au marché
on va faire un cahier sur l'album c'est
quand je trouve ça ça part un peu comme
gailly et la bombe a gagné les écoutes
gagner peu toi plaisir mais je préfère
dégager les albums
marchera marchera pas moi je m'appelle
je pourrais parler un petit peu de
patton que tu fais pareil par humour
lesieu que tout ce trip tueries dans le
studio et puis ça finit par marcher mais
j'avais parlé beaucoup adam où la
demande est arrivé lui ce qu'ils disent
c'est que même avant qu'ils aillent à
occupation double si les affaires des
gros becs commencé à lever qui lui
comprenez comme pas trop pourquoi
parceque il faisait juste des niaiseries
faisait des niaiseries fois que ces
doutes on était complètement gelé mais
six mois plus de 17 dans le studio m
pour un petit truc qui avait mené plus
en plus me rends compte comme fois que
mme aubry ont tout québec puis on dirait
que au québec un peu plus c'est un peu
plus humoristique je vous à l'e3 encore
rien de sérieux la danse et tout
disparaît beau joe cole qui fait que la
classe amateur aussi qu'ils avaient
éclaté les gens sa porte et j'ai dit oui
c'est vrai c'est gérald larose a apporté
leur appui logistique clairement sa
place à la classique puis soumah souvent
ce qu'ils prennent des bains tout de
même qu'ils sont pas humoriste x et des
espèces de catch frise humoristique le
qui se faisait mettons pour reprendre
l'exemple de
de loud le sage la ligne préférée de
l'ordre qui s'est mis pour un petit
bémol pour un croissant et suscitent ces
faux kingston est pas drôle mais ce
genre sont vraiment forts c'est bon non
non c'est important d'aider comme
l'écriture d'abord une plume qui comme
qui est pas juste dire sur ce sujet de
la venue d'une certaine façon c'est
toujours le fun c'est lui puis c'est ce
sens que ce soit drôle je te demande si
ça pète et qu'il risque d'une façon qui
est comique ou une figure qui est drôle
puis 16 pouces assaf beaucoup la boucle
avec richard desjardins qu'on parlait au
début parce que lui c'est ce qui fait
partie il donne son sang pour sang
l'humain 15% pour sa pensée donner son
vrai pour ça toute la semaine avec après
ce moment là dit il
originaire d'ukraine tourne à la
personne qui faisait la tribu quasi avec
un la classe ça serait bon que vous avez
une chance d'enregistrer que je me
connais un qui m'importe qu'est ce qu'on
fait mais moi j'adore ça c'est mon
boulot de préférer mon meilleur jour j
avais dit jamais magna com site allemand
d'opel thon rouge à la cites cas -
réflexion faite sous henri que je t'ai
pas son pied
le lendemain la moto comme un hangar
c'est le même c'est un génie de la
musique c'est vraiment là
jenny la musique celui qui a fait la
[ __ ] les gens timmons habite l'homme au
tibet comme les gentils manège anti je
te vois mg bid ox claude bégin à son
meilleur toujours dans le coup gentil
non les gc ca walt est gentil je me
trompe avec jean tigana qu'on essaye de
tout temps dira jean tigana mais les
gentils de médecine m'a fait me motive
la plupart de ses projets solo si tu
m'avais dit c'est que c'est claude
dupont fait des arrangements d'une pop
qui sont justement de woippy de style
goya pas y'a pas pour ça les coleman
fallait un management vous n'êtes pas
manille quand elle avait effectué guette
un petit peu de technique puis tout pour
réussir le titre boa vent la mer
technique ceci l'a dit messi que tu
penses que tu fais ça va pas être beau
et il aurait l'oreille des idées mais
d'écouter de la musique inspirée après
semaine ya pas la musique aussi
qu'inspirant choses notamment patrick
groulx ça m'inspire etc j'ai un film ça
peut inspirer
jusqu'à maintenant on line dans la vie
de tous les jours je vais à l'autre des
puits la personne attaquée c'est un gros
flocons me parler parce que c'est drôle
mais chaque personne a une façon de
parler
chaque personne a une façon de parler
chaque personne en face on parle il veut
c'est chacun comment tu parles oh ça va
bien ça va mieux si comme chacun
vraiment des notes différentes la casse
et au dépanneur tout le monde
ça c'est drôle bas ce qui en fait la
mère de mon beau père qui a ici en fait
il faudrait aller manger chez elle peu
témoins à charge ont justement fait de
ce stage il peut pas l'oublier fait
qu'en marchant aussi lui cela rappelle
plus faire ouvrir une chanson so fresh
pitrou quel genre de projet m'intrigue
et pau 64 bits ou sur spotify puis tout
parce qu'il ya les stars bid m
voyons des manu chao en fait fait qu'on
la nomme populaire et g60 clamait jeudi
au congrès d inspiration des personnes
qui peuvent parler c'est jean leloup qui
disait c'est ce qu' il ya beaucoup de
monde qui voit jean leloup parler à voix
haute marche un deuxième temps à côté de
chez nous mais jamais par la vue et que
je travaille des fois il laisse à son
peuple
seule la brasse et changer de place
notamment l'histoire de jean loup mais
en tout cas c'est le le monde qu'il voit
marcher puis chante comme un espace qui
voit quelque chose serait une idée
ils nous prennent les marches il veut
pas l'oublier marche au rythme sa
chanson qui il chante en anglais chante
à voix haute mais il voit comme parce
qu'ils portent autant annoncer d'autres
assistants rapport avant sentence et fly
me surprendrait pas qu'il fasse un album
de rap même
team avec les minorités jean leloup le
bit rappelle genre vraiment de
redressement qui l'envoie sur ses sauts
qui très près ce genre de gars qui doit
titre ibf surtout peu importe si c'est
bon il sait si créatif c'est un
phénomène propre au genre paris 6 à 16,5
ou d'années déjà fait l'an prochain à
chaque site ça sonne un peu comme un
dernier album ça sonnait comme un
aboutissement
ça sonnait comme un dernier album je
serais pas surpris que je sont en
entente juste parlé mais moi je pense
pas parce que c'est de là il y aura été
un peu comme un petit commis pour
refaire un album puis faire des tournées
toutefois comme cacher mes gars là est
plus le genre d'album lancement puis
après c'est justement à man city je
pense qu'il ya sûrement avoir besoin
d'après moi j'en financière besoin de
faire un nouvel album
pizango savoir s'il n'a pas besoin de
parler shopi ça rapporte le lui la
sensation il doit encore toucher pas mal
avec c'est une console encore là c'est
même moi je pense que je pense que j'en
ai lu ou s'il n'y a pas l'air stressé de
comment vivre sans doute comme jour au
jour le jour pige or le titre jal est
écouté
l'invitation est lancée lundi au podcast
gens là dessus mon dos et ça c'est notre
si on apprend que jean louis les fans
podcast
il y attend juste qu'on connaît
personnellement dirigé le toi tu vis tu
maintenant j'ose du rap exclusivement
fait et j'ai aussi l'avantagé d'un petit
mon père qui me rase pas payer de loyer
ce qui est un bon avantage que ce fait
que je peux je pourrais en fait
éventuellement être décotés
non c'est ça c'est cool mais je peux
vivre d'être à fond j'ai vraiment fait
ça à temps plein c'est ce qui fait que
tu peux être productif centre où des
tirs ont visé j'imagine si ça te tente
où se pose la question comment tu
expliques la montée fulgurante mettons
le ton succès les petits j'ai
l'impression que c'est pas la faire
peut-être le rap qui fonctionne mais
aussi le fait de tous les ancêtres des
tracts dans un nouveau projet une
nouvelle fois que vous procure plus
aussi parce que pour pas il ya tellement
plus de musique alanguie comme t'as pas
le choix si tu veux parce que comme là
c'est sûr que j'ai déjà un nom donc je
pourrais attendre 3 ans ancien album
puis le monde voudrait carrément
l'écouté mois mais surtout quand on sait
qu'en foot tu fasses ton nom tu t'en
fous tu travailles pour pour ta job en
poche walkom du zulia des sorties alors
si ce projet je pense que c'est une
piste comme ceux qui quels bousseta à
l'avenir plus connus dès jeudi si elle à
l'époque ce qu'on élève de paul choix
revenait trop productif parce qu'il y en
a tout le temps un autre qui va le
sortir une heure après de quoi tu puis
après si je te demande quand le terrain
saâd année le celi peut justement faire
patienter
c'était pourtant connu doit sortir des
copies au québec où je vais aller voir
la balle parce que la boyle ou sorti lui
aussi ressorti trois nouveautés
c'était toujours thaçi français pour
l'artiste
de se faire connaître ou semences qui
t'as pas le choix d'être ultra produits
productif au début surtout que les
plateformes de streaming dans tout le
monde tessa démocratise tellement la
musique des projets d'avant les bottes
des projets dans ce sens que le temps
ainsi c'est trop c'est trop facile
d'écouter de la musique c'est fake c'est
difficile d'écouter de nous mettons de
faire écouter justice et c'est plutôt
floue mais les vidéos six autres des
vidéos de temps la vidéo si encore la
maxime desfossez quasiment c'est
vraiment beau et c'est vraiment cool
même si des fois c'est quasiment un
puriste d'argent tu avoues sortir un fou
clip tout au final cela tourne calme on
aime le plus ouais au final ils vont à
l'écouté juste l'album petit convoi
s'est jamais vraiment à quoi t'attendre
gailly même ceux qui pleurent le pire et
un après midi le fait deux trois chocs
et là on a juste rouler des batchs mini
bagdad c'est ça on a fait d'autres clips
ou ski avec des gros groupes comme métis
c'est pas là tout qu'elles montrent qu'à
part peut-être 200 m les clips qu'elle
monte capote
mais c'est important d'avoir décrit par
exemple c'est important parce que c'est
sur le monde il faut qu'ils le voient à
manille c'est important je pense de mes
temps est un artiste c'est important de
pas je suppose des photos mais
t'aimerais mois sur la plage moenner
mosimane au moulin mais c'est quand même
important quel monde comme un artiste un
package de moi je pense toujours
[Musique]
conformé à préparer toulouse c'est qui
les croquis moi je te vois un mec ki
moon
non non mais sans blague c'est toi en
plus de la musique et l'image
participation pitié même plus loin que
ce qui crée une espèce de parler lexique
que tu crées mes tantes et les motive en
dessous ça crie un genre de sentiment
d'appartenance pour tes fans s'est créé
une espèce de sous cultures qui font que
comme les khelifa neufs qu'ils ont on
parle un langage pense qu'on prend puis
on est une gang 6e j'aimerais que ça
contribue vraiment si c'est vraiment
comme moi c'est ça arrive un peu tout
seul puis de mons rendu compte aussi 2
10e ouais quand quand justement le monde
13 et du monde par rapport qui faisait
répondre à ces magistrats sont aussi des
matchs de poule première forcé lundi on
a tellement petit jusqu'à la cloche
côtoie la main sortant de boîtes fois
comme chaque map est vraiment un peu
aussi son poids sur son site ligne un
peu et puis après c'est en est qui
inventent plus de mots que d'autres
comme moi puis à la claire maintenant
quand même normal inventer des trucs
mais c'est toute la bataille stein silva
s'est pas dit il faut que je m'écris mon
niveau ça si comme c'est juste des mots
qu'on utilise dans la vie tous les jours
parfaitement jésus-christ paix sur ce
domaine je peux vous connaissez sûrement
non mais on ne connaît pas dans une
chicha s'est posé on est dans une chicha
s'imposait j'aime à me plaît j'ai l'oeil
arrête pas on est jeune on est sisi je
me souviens année dans un badge avec un
je pense on est posée jan aps le bac
sont déposés après le bac je sais et
puis tout le monde apprécie qu'on va
rester un peu sans moi je trouve ça
comme un jeu c'est drôle aussi
switch au parc mais aussi de capter pas
dans ta vie mais sait-on l'x et ont
laissé au sujet
mais vous connaissez l'amalgamme qui est
un groupe de rap c'est des amis c'est de
la fourmilière pas mal puis on fait
l'amalgamé on commence un peu la maison
de l'amalgamé sont comme des collègues
c'est la partie ce qui t'a ma clause à
[Musique]
rentrer dans la partie
boya bhl j&j le trouveront ça crie ça
j'ai dit pourquoi pas le titre mais
justement quatre boutons gars de
l'amalgamé est il reprit à sa manière
mais le risque est qu'ils disent les
slits je veux dire je suis comme ça
c'est possible c'est super drôle c'est
des trucs de même que je dis pourquoi
pas justement ali préface que je sais
pas c'est simple un truc
pourquoi pas j'ai vu il y avait un
documentaire sur l'île ouen qui était
loué bac puis il disait lui c'est le
premier sur terre pas avoir fait bling
bling
alors inventé bling-bling playes
expliquer c'est quelque chose pour les
jo c'est tellement important à maintenir
la varappe c'est être aussi justement
c'était comme des outils 10 des mots
importants qu'il est beau monstre la
société l'indicé bon durable comme son
nom mais je te mords man est juste le
faisais je peux moi place de rap et tout
le monde espère un os ça donne ça donne
de quoi si ça donne juste des quartz et
comme pour toute ma force qui voit qu'il
est je peux continuer à entendre la paix
nous
oh c'est juste des trucs de même le
caire où tu peux amener des mots qui ont
éventuellement d'ablettes à cause des
dates de wax en fait c'est tout
bagdad
en constante évolution
s'il n'a pas vraiment mais elle a quand
même été virale son truc l'opt et moi je
me souviens en plus quand j'avais comme
prospectus est intentionnel 5 ont choisi
des petites sessions fustal de nos
matches pim futur les huit ans et j'ai
encore les vieux rideaux comme les
onomatopées
pourquoi cas pas cas pas tout pourquoi
pas mamadou
ça a dû former ce camp parlais tantôt le
dos capable de créer un ok ça a dû
développer sur ces classiques lent parce
que c'est ça c'est comme un mouton
fiscale useful stop le fauteuil des mots
à mettons sur un beat ya tout le temps
le petit truc de faut que je réfléchisse
à ce que je dis mais kurt temps fou des
mômes qui surgissent ya ali comme
commente on tente encore phil le bit ses
lecteurs avec des flocons possibles
notamment commis un raid j'aurais jamais
pensé à ça c'est ce qui se dit des
choses justes dans le groupe les choses
un peu
[Musique]
ça marche qui sait ce qu'est ce qu'ils
font c'est d'avoir le premier comme un
premier sens en ce moment mettre des
mots mais je sois premier première idée
dirigé de l'usiné manac sort de ces
malades
ça me fait vraiment penser à l'écriture
automatique et en littérature enfants
quand on veut juste comme une espèce d
exercices d'échauffement on veut se
préparer à être capable d'écrire souvent
associés pour lutter contre le syndrome
de la page blanche
jacques biton le dessus pendant cinq
minutes écrit tout à fait justes écrit
l'amanite tue trouve des photos de la
soldate maximum à disposition il faut
maintenant je te manger j'écoute une
chanson plus j'ai dit d'accord pour
parler d'être seul mais des fois une
chanson comme fox
l'atonie pokémon mais je sais pas quoi
par les latinos l'excellent jeu dimanche
face à nice après que le sujet précède
c'est comme ça des fois qu'il touchait
chaque dans l'album bousquet je me
souviens tu à québec puis en inde un
grand face de l'hôtel trois clubs en
fait parce que je t'adore et avec ma
blonde to play tout le monde peut se
coucher à l'hôtel dans le chemin
dernière clope c'est que les ul vite la
manif patron parle plaît aux gens ce
sont certains a rappelé jeudi
j'irai ils ont les cheveux comme ouais
ouais ok c'est bon t'as raison et j'ai
toujours raison
jetez moi le luxe
j'ai toujours elle a agit toujours rêve
à
ah j'ai toujours fais tu sais aller avec
ce genre de good trip de jaune les gris
qui pensent que tout le temps raison qui
fait chier dans le fond un qui saisit
dans l'antre chose que moi tu peux
m'appeler juke connaissance des tricks
de même le fait que la table on sait pas
pourquoi mon nom d'oiseau son panier
pour nom 6 annoncé sa manchette ces
raisons la chicane parce que j'aimerais
que ce frêle en plus de j'ai toujours
raison dans l'hôtel surmonter y y
ils font appel le micro à l'hôtel ça ils
s'en foutent ils informés qu'ils
appellent une question la question mon
oncle et mettons là parce que tu mettes
ongles une coupe d'oeuvre gaye est celle
de deux ans à peu près de 70 sort ce 19
20 et un petit rhume débattent dans la
banque les petits pas d'être gelée et
tenter parole
si je sais que ce n'est pas la musique
porté par mills qui capote est ok ok je
me suis là le temps dans le temps le
temps justement cela que l'abattage
on faisait du team dans ce temps les
jeux typés sort et anticipateur aussi
fait qu'on faisait de un peu de
anticipateur les charges pour ta bille
mettez sur le tire vraiment désormais
tellement mais dont michael pour libérer
sa compagne maintenant c'est sur ces
seuls camions des bus en fait non pas
que le vidéo c'est ça aurait pu aussi me
disent pas mais c'est râpé toutes choses
que je suis pas dans le bio c'est pas
mal le seul sait comment ce que feront
pas le monde il a dicté cousin et le 10
mai
non c'est sûr que c'est quelque chose de
calme
justement comme come easy swap à la
musique pour mes parents et j'ai fait ce
pianiste et comme bons mais j'étais en
avance mais je savais très doux et
madjid joint qui tentent de pousser les
bars préparer legault a juste à cause
des trucks soldats partout le passé à
l'état cubain y a des il ya des gros et
fidel castro les gros et drapeaux des la
fougue et sa soul as qui désirent en
concert par les drs qu'il fasse un petit
avion dash entre le prêtre ne sait pas
où il est mais je me sentais mal c'était
quoi c'était une journée
c'est une journée légendaire mémoire
appelez la comme akon chante une toune
n'avait pas c'est quoi
[Rires]
peu de noms mais en fait j'en faisais
quand j'étais adolescent à l'école
maintenant tous les x qui nos jours de
cavale travail d'équipé dans le coin
avec tout le temps des barreaux rappelé
safin sec et au plus près ce qui se
passe à boules on ne trouve une réponse
qui était vraiment bon plus mais à
manier chez juste fait comme fuck off
les barreaux c'est drôle du tout mais je
préfère une chanson je trouve c'est
comme si le fun écouter une chanson qui
coûtera le club héraultais
et puis mais non je t'ai je ne suis pas
d'accord
non mais c'est ça n'est pas que c'est
quand même vraiment du travail pour
google c'est ça c'est ça que je trouve
un peu chiant c'est surtout en plus avec
les ténors tellement choqué stop pendant
le temps d'écrire sur un go pas de bruit
pas envie non plus deux comme écrit sur
quelqu'un parlant de la nuque criant ce
que tu penses que je serai pas encore
[Rires]
c'est fou ce très malade lui s'appelle
et ont tagué prophète sous ce label est
ce possible leurs frères bryan ruiz
twente un album à la demande un peu de
temps mais il ya quand même une gîte est
débordé tous n'ont malheureusement der
bach maintenant c'est sûr que c'est
quand même pas parce qu'il pose sur mon
album qui est onze mois plus bas n'ont
cessé que les tories a accueilli ce
toujours fous quitter ou des fêtes un
peu défi trois années j'ai un futur ap
non au contraire
au bout mais non sa future belle-fille
québécois ya pas beaucoup de filles par
exemple mais comme à chaque fit c'est
toujours plus qu'un artiste européen
couilles de w9 humaine est rempli d et
steed estivale au meilleur des cinq
je pense qu'il va plus vraiment par
exemple un film c'est vrai qu'il a fait
est fait mais j'ai lancé m e rang des
photos de lui où se déploie à tokyo où
ce que personne ne reconnaissent pas mes
doigts et doit son dernier album ça a
été bon bloc comme seul genre n'est qu'
on entend peu parler ici d'un tas parce
que maupassant camp qu'ils écrivent
elles
or là elle est très très fort mais non
mais c'est ainsi en a plein d'autres
bons frères
enfin arabes et européens je dirais que
j'aime beaucoup beaucoup et le rap belge
quasiment plus que le rap français
et c'est comme si chaque à bayrou jean
s'est amusé m chrissie nos moeurs et je
dirais cela aussi j'aime bien aussi
lord esperanza qu'il faut te fit avec 13
autres que j'avais j'ai découvert
justement en faisant office avec
connaissais pas vraiment fan de booba
j'adore ta carte bleue mais comme à
parité moi je le connais pas le temps de
lunatic topo fais tes devoirs mongel n'a
pas fait de ne pas adresser leurs apps
souci même dit mec que j'aime bien
beaucoup de technologies j'ai pas le
choix
t'as pas envie de faire de quoi qui
ressemble à quelqu'un qui est encore là
des fois aussi page et codés comme je
t'aime fort mais pourquoi pour moi qui
ai fait cette chanson là c'est important
aussi dessèche pas ça non mais pauvre s
et je pense est important d'écouter
vraiment surtout comme quand tu fais
sauter jeu de dames à tanger pour monter
un jour dans l'équipe tchèque pollender
qu'il est un joueur faut que tu saches
taittinger pour le choix je pense ça
fait partie de ma job sur toute la
musique tu es évolue tellement vite que
les jeunes chercheurs vont vite qui est
ici gap à jour même tes vit depuis dans
game notes de jazz c'est toujours bon
pied ce soir
mais c'est prescrit quatre écoutes
mettant son dernier 4 it comes to buy a
progressé la nissan leaf est pas le gros
le gros chat qui est qui qui qui lance
maman rapport que tu écoutes
il faut quand même c'est dommage tout
péter mais quand j'écoute sont très
souvent des rapports men qui ont marqué
la musique
sauf que patte blanche petit tout
[Musique]
sa salle a ouvert les portes est à ce
stade la question récemment pêche
moi j'écoute pas mal j'aime beaucoup
beaucoup au minimum que je vais pas me
soucier de leurs trouvailles non non
c'est clair que 4 5 millions des coûts
sinon même pour son attitude de marde
j'aime bien grosse way est bâtie comme
c'est drôle je suis un fan fini des
crânes mon gamin terrain certes il
entame sa nouvelle traque les gens
récemment sorti en est une qui vise à
marchés hispanophones
[Musique]
non mais il est revenu comme uae et
ghazali comme philippe se passer comme
ça maintenant je fais égayer le tout le
monde oublie plus tard monde serait
gagnant l'espagnol mène depuis ça
marcherait non cm scène brésilienne
je pense mais quand j'entends les gens
un peu pâle c'était comme mais je
comprends pas tout mais c'est vraiment
bon j'écoute ce tout le temps le
dimanche il a tout fait un feat
tu la mets en espagnol mais tu exploses
la place le comme des riches c'est à
dire
libéré de l'espace tout oui c'est ce qui
a amené la traque à un haut niveau
même s y est
étienne drapeau men fait des tonnes en
espagnol et ma femme tu es la plus belle
il fallait une version espagnole du
poignet plus que tu es ma femme je
pourrais pas le résultat final c'est
donc un peu ce que je pense à semaine
qui se bat ce qu'il fallait
il parlait de musique mais ce panneau
puis dans le fond c'est drôle parce que
vu que j'étais à cuba pour masseube où
j'ai beaucoup d'inspiration espagnole
puis dans l'album est justement il ya
deux refrains qui sont comme en espagnol
c'est comme gagner c'est un cruel quand
même dans le vanity fait que j'ai écrit
dans une lettre de zvi que c'est quand
même un espagnol pau pyrénées c'est
plein de trucs mais en fait moi je
trouve qu'elle est longuement boston
richesse des trucs et pourquoi pourquoi
ce s'oublie g à rester je sens français
traille à toulouse il ya tout tout le
sud pourrait parler russe même que je
trouverais ça marche très bien dans une
chanson que le ferai mes mom de russes à
montréal si vous en faut quatre ans pour
une bière
[Rires]
bah ouais c'est fini
enfin après 5,1 de breuil à votre chalet
ton flow 2 puis il m'avait mythique à
verser c'est fou parce que c'est après
ce qu'est ce qu'ils disent ce qu'ils ont
et comment je sais pas c'était possible
mes yeux la voix un peu plus graves
comme celui qui aimait tellement beau
rappelé
jusqu'à mi mollet par un grand bal à
pied très juste pas capable d'articuler
de congrès en pis de certainement gauche
a fait tiquer inventé le monde s'est
lui-même ses huit élus sur le réseau
vous allez trouver quelqu'un d'autre
festi c'est le seul et l'unique
inventeur du moment même la lumière
merci me fait plaisir
un podcast et m
[Musique]